[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute gibt es mal
wieder eine motiv torte von mir denn
hasbro hat mich gefragt ob ich mir nicht
zum neuen film my little pony eine neue
generation was hübsches und leckeres
einfallen lassen möchte und habe ich
natürlich sofort gesagt ja mach ich und
am ende des videos gibt es sogar noch
drei große brandneuem eine deponie
figuren zu gewinnen was ihr dafür tun
müsst das sage ich euch dann wie gesagt
am ende des videos und wir schauen uns
jetzt einfach mal den trailer an vor
langer zeit lebte er von spd und
einhörner in harmonie miteinander
vielleicht finden wir dass eines tages
raus
[Musik]
fast so
neue freundin wald
[Applaus]
gegen alle prinzip mir steht ewig
dankbar sein
ihr sohn ist in sicherheit man
das ist nicht mein kind so schön
wie du meinst du dass
[Musik]
du dann keine magie wir hatten mal
welche aber da ist die post gefunden
[Musik]
die wir machen uns auf den weg nach
bereits die peter system ist heraus
wissen dass mit auch energie geschehen
ist und sie als spieler bringen aber die
petersilie nicht halt unsere freunde
ein einhorn und ein pony okay ich glaub
das wird heute noch interessant
[Musik]
besonders viel glück
ich liebe es nicht sagt matthias kommt
liebe ponys
aufgepasst die ultimative zellen
nein ich spiele nicht ich gebe mir große
worte für so ein kleines pony du warst
schon bald haben eine größe überzeugt
sein
[Musik]
dankeschön dankeschön
keine fotos okay einen punkt
ab dem 24
september könnt ihr euch den film
exklusiv bei netflix angucken und wer
ist mit my little pony auch groß
gewordene ich persönlich kenne es noch
vom frühjahr liegt bei den schwestern
nichten neffen alle so meinte tony jaa
und deswegen habe ich mich umso mehr
gefreut dass diese motiv torte backen
kann ich habe auch direkt angefangen mit
meinem saftigen schoko boden dazu gibt's
ja schon ein basic rezept auf einem
kanal worauf ich hatte immer verlinke
damit das video auch nicht zu lang wird
und das habe ich halt vorgebacken ich
werde euch alle ganz genauen angaben
dazu in die infobox schreiben und ich
habe immer so kleinen trick damit er
nicht austrocknet nämlich einfach
küchenpapier macht das ein bisschen nass
bringen das aus und dann lasse ich den
boden einfach darunter auskühlen so und
weiter geht's mit der gage dafür habe
ich einfach zart peter kurth ihre fein
gehackt und zusammen mit sahne in einem
topf gekocht beziehungsweise nicht ganz
aufkochen lassen sondern wirklich nur
erwärmen so dass es sich miteinander
verbindet und anschließend das tier das
auch komplett auskühlen
[Musik]
jetzt zeige ich euch einmal im vergleich
wie die danach aussieht direkt nach dem
erwärmen deshalb auch nicht zu heiss
erwärmen so dass perfekt und nach dem
auskühlen sieht sie dann so aus und ich
bin persönlich fern davon dass einfach
auf zimmertemperatur 45 stunden
auskühlen zu lassen wenn die gefahr ist
groß dass wenn es in den kühlschrank tun
und das vergisst dass es dann zu fest
wird auch dann könnte man nachhelfen
indem er ein wasserbad nimmt und auch
nochmal durch wird aber so ist perfekt
und ich persönlich hab zum vortrag
vorbereitet das könnt ihr auch machen so
und jetzt machen wir die leckere sahne
creme für die leckere seine kämen
nämlich jetzt meine küche maschine ihr
könnt natürlich wie immer auch ein
handrührgerät benutzen und ich nehme
jetzt eine creme die besteht
größtenteils aus mascarpone und sahne
einfach damit es nicht zu weich ist weil
es halt immer noch ein motiv torte die
muskeln standfest sein und ja damit sie
eben nicht zu schokolade ist und wie ein
schönes mittelmaß an habe ich mich hier
noch mal für die mascarpone sahne creme
entschieden gibt es jetzt alles in die
küchenmaschine mascarpone warne zucker
und vanille extrakt und rühre dass so
lange bis es so halb steigt ist gibt
dann sanft und ruhig dann komplett
steigt
[Musik]
so die sahne creme ist jetzt auch fertig
ich probiere man
sofern mind rot weiß wer man diesen
schokoladigen schoko boden der super
saftig ist die zitadelle und dann noch
mal wirklich diese sahne creme sehr sehr
lecker ich will nicht alles schichten
und dafür lebe ich mir also erstmal den
ersten boden und falls ihr euch gefragt
habe warum machst du zwei bestandteile
warum einmal gar schon einmal seine
creme liegt nicht nur an dem geschmack
sondern auch daran dass seine nicht in
verbindung bzw in der form nicht in
verbindung mit fondant geraten darf weil
es sonst zu feucht ist und der von
danzig lösen würde und aus dem grund
werde ich jetzt gleich einen gerne
schräge spritzen das zeige ich euch
gleich am besten dem jetzt hier nochmal
meinen tortenring außenrum damit alles
schön gerade ist und dann fange ich an
ich habe mir übrigens meine garage noch
mal in meinem sprits heute mittwoch
tolle vorne dran gefüllt weil so kann
man den ring einfach einfacher spritzen
[Musik]
die torte wird jetzt geschichtet ich
habe immer zwei gar nach strenger an den
rand gibt dann die sahne creme rein und
wenn ihr möchte das aber nur optional
könnt ihr noch getrocknete früchte und
ob legen ich persönlich mag es wenn es
noch eine kleine fruchtige note gibt und
eine ganz oben angekommen seid einmal
mit ghanas abschließen damit die
oberfläche ist auch nicht trocken wird
und dann für mindestens 30 minuten in
den kühlschrank stellen das habe ich
jetzt schon gemacht und ich nehme jetzt
meinen xxl tortenring messer und geht es
ganz vorsichtig mit der schmalen klinger
am rand entlang und sobald wir unten
angekommen sind sehen super wichtig dass
wir das ganz vorsichtig macht einmal im
kreis drehen und so lösen wir jetzt die
torte von im ring ohne uns die garage
gleich wegzureißen
bevor jetzt die von dann decke drauf
kommt müssen wir noch einen schritt
erledigen und zwar die torte komplett
mit ghanas einstreichen ich persönlich
mache es so die erste schicht da gebe
ich mir nicht so viel mühe das bindet
einfach die krümel dann gäbe es für zehn
minuten in die kühlung also in den
kühlschrank und dann kommen die zweite
schicht on top und die muss richtig
schön gerade sein und sobald die auch
noch mal zehn minuten gekühlt können wir
den fondant ausrollen und einmal die
torte richtig schön damit eindecken
[Musik]
die torte habe ich jetzt schon
eingedeckt ich habe mich übrigens extra
für die baby blaue tortenplatte
entschieden und für so eine mintgrüne
fondant decke einfach weil ich auch
möchte dass die torte richtig schön bunt
ist genauso wie gerade im trailer sehen
konntet euch die neuen farben
aufgefallen also im trailer geht es
eigentlich darum bzw man merkt dass
quest ria seine magie verloren hat und
ehrt ponys einhörner und picasso einfach
keine freunde mehr sind und wie ist dann
ausgeht dass er natürlich im film ich
schaue mir persönlich auch direkt am 24
entweder mit hamza oder vielleicht nehme
ich meinen nichten noch dazu ich werde
jetzt den grip vorbereiten und damit so
richtig schön bunt wird habe ich hier
auf der spitze meines löffelt so ein
bisschen roter lebensmittelfarbe und die
gebe ich jetzt hier in die saale die
fertig gleich so ein bisschen rosa dann
gebe ich dafür die mikrowelle erwärmen
das allerdings nicht hochkochen sondern
wirklich nur erwerben dann einmal auf
die weiße kuvertüre geben und schmelzen
lassen
[Musik]
mein tipp ist jetzt doch ein bisschen
knalliger geworden ich habe zwar alles
so ein bisschen in pastellfarben aber es
hat verdammt schwierig weiße schokolade
zu färben daher statt sohn apricot habe
ich mich lieber führen pink entschieden
und ich finde das match trends gut ich
mache jetzt aber in der zwischenzeit
während das so ein bisschen runter kühlt
im betrieb besser läuft manche schon mal
die deko ich habe es übrigens gestern
schon vorbereitet weil ich es immer
besser finde wenn sie halt ein bisschen
aushärtet ich habe hier fondant in
verschiedenen pastellfarben bekommt ihr
ganz leicht hin indem ihr einfach so ein
bisschen lebensmittelfarbe verwendet und
nicht allzu viel und jetzt fange ich an
mir den von dann in den verschiedensten
farben einfach zu so einem strang zu
rollen und dann zeige ich euch wie ihr
ganz einfach in diesen regenbogen
hinbekommt
[Musik]
sondern auf der rückseite gebe ich es
noch schlick spieße drauf und ein
bisschen vom band mit wasser das dient
dann so ein bisschen als kleber und so
können wir das dann ein bisschen
aushärten lassen und später auch die
torte stecken jetzt nächstes noch einmal
richtig hübsche lollipops so wir nehmen
uns jetzt ein dickes stück weißes vom
band rollen das zu einer wurst und kann
auch ruhig ein bisschen dicker sein und
da gehen wir verschiedene farben als
dünn strang einfach und ob
die seite ich habe jetzt auch
verschiedene lollis in verschiedenen
farben und auch verschiedenen größen da
gebe ich jetzt violett dann nämlich
orange und rosa und dann einfach nur
noch mal so ein bisschen auf der
arbeitsfläche rollen anschließend ein
drehen damit es musste auch noch mal ein
bisschen schöner wird und dann rollen
wir das quasi zu so einem lolli 1
[Musik]
ich finde meine brötchen richtig sie ist
öfter gesehen wie schnell sich die
gezaubert habe einfach weise volland
üblichen form und mit dünner weise von
der decke und ob legen gefällt mir
richtig gut und als nächstes schaue ich
mir mal einen trip an
der müsste jetzt
der fließen noch ein bisschen zu schnell
ich warte jetzt noch fünf minuten und
dann gebe ich den grip einfach auf die
torte gibt eine ganze deko on top und da
haben wir besorgt mir gerade noch
richtig süßes pony figuren die kommen
auch noch oben drüber und dann ist die
torte auch schon fertig
[Musik]
und um jetzt beim einem gewinnspiel
teilnehmen zu können seit ganz einfach
abonnenten eines kanals und schreibt
hier unten in die kommentare welche
figur aus my little pony ihren
allerliebsten mögt und jetzt wünsch euch
ganz viel spaß beim test so jetzt werden
nur noch
da fehlt noch was bin ja
okay jetzt ein die magie stimmt dafür
ist unklar
jetzt haben wir die marines kommend ist
es machen wir fühlen uns ist jeder oder
spott und komm doch rein weist wir haben
hier die saftigen schoko würden dann die
takte takahashi quadratmeter damit es
nicht zu süß wie jetzt sind sollte man
ja auch voll mich nehmen können und
keine sahne creme mit früchten
ich wollte ich nicht unterbrechen ich
wollte noch einmal sorgen dass sich
jetzt alle komponenten mich sehr aber
ich muss auch noch mal
die magie der glitter gibt es ganz
normalen kick ohne gitter so klagte sein
kann schauen ja das ist der geldmacht
alles aus hier haben sich gut gemacht so
chocolat und weich und sehr sehr sehr
patienten das wirtschaft ag ist nicht so
ist nicht dieses fünfziger sein sagt
dieser film genommen im boden dazu fällt
mir ein paar säcke er sich also ich
mache mein eigenes ich glaube kinder
wenn das leben erst mal wegen der optik
aber auch so ist schokoladige nicht nur
außen wunderschön sondern die inneren
werte mit dem kuchen 10 auf
oder ich bin verblüfft ich hab mich
gerade so schön meinte servo und außen
fondant in aber doch wie figuren aus und
sind das genau die figur ich habe sie
jetzt nicht aus.von land gefährlich
gesorgt
und begann zu einem spielball an wenn
ihr möchtet dass ich irgendwann mal
zeige wie man meine deponie aus fondant
macht treibt schon jetzt gerne in die
kommentare
ansonsten finde ich so einfach perfekt
weil es auch nicht zu viel zeit in
anspruch nimmt ist auch eine schöne
geburtstagsfeier für alles ja auch
bilderbücher war genau also schaut euch
die deponie eine neue generation nach
netflix an haben zusammen wir gehen uns
mission zusammen genau wissen nicht mehr
und werfen dann bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]